am 14 märz ist landtagswahl in baden
württemberg und wir haben auf youtube
unserer userinnen und user gefragt
welche themen sie besonders
interessieren
ich treffe jetzt gleich hier geht es vor
allem um das thema drogenpolitik bzw die
legalisierung von cannabis
[Musik]
benelli ich bin 39 jahre alt
informatikerin von beruf und ab vor 25
jahren zum ersten mal gekifft
ich bin mutter zweier kinder allein
erziehen mit den kindern gehe ich den
fußballverein zweimal die woche am
wochenende die wir dann auf turnieren
wir sind auch aktive laakirchen
ich hatte halt auch starke perioden
schmerzen und beschwerden und durch das
kiffen ist ist alles viel besser
geworden also die schmerzen und deswegen
bin ich dabei geblieben trotzdem eine
schule gemacht ausbildung und alles ja
allerdings bewegt man sich ja dann auch
so illegal weil cannabis jahr verboten
ist und das ist mir auch dann zum
verhängnis geworden weil da werden einem
jahr dann auch andere drogen angeboten
und dann wenn ich da leider
reingerutscht somit 17
und ja erst mal war dass so ein
experimentieren ausprobieren aber ja das
mit dem heroin das hat dann halt schon
abhängig gemacht und wenn da ein paar
jahre drin gesteckt allerdings trotz sei
dank halleluja mit der hilfe von ärzten
und mit der hilfe von cannabis dann
geschafft von den harten drogen wieder
wegzukommen dauerhaft und jetzt ganz ist
schon 15 jahre her dass familie ist
einfach die hölle
also gerade als frau wenn man da rein
rutscht weil die dealer die nutzen ihre
position ja auch schamlos aus also wenn
man da echt nicht knallhart ist da da
geht man einfach unter in die millionen
sind die menschen müssen wissen wer mit
einer parallelgesellschaft aber das ist
hier das ist da das betrifft uns und es
ist ein schreckliches gefühl auf einer
kriminell zu sein weil ich mach doch
alles gut ich mach doch was man von mir
erwartet ich mache schule und die
gesellschaft möchte mich eigentlich gar
nicht haben nur weil ich jetzt eine
töpferin bin werde ich halt kein bier
mag oder dass nicht vertrage ich würde
nicht sagen dass cannabis ungefährlich
ist es schon auf jeden fall ein
rauschmittel ist es halt auch ein
heilmittel für viele menschen und
deswegen sollte es auf jeden fall
zugänglich gemacht werden für mich ich
bin froh dass ich ist jetzt auch auf
rezept wegen chronischen rückenschmerzen
die jetzt im lockdown unerträglich
geworden sind und dass ich jetzt endlich
aus der kriminalität raus bin ich war
schon jahre davor auch schon bei ersten
gewesen und ja dann halleluja haben es
endlich geschafft ein arzt zu finden der
gesagt hat ja ich verschreibe ihnen das
was ist deine konkrete frage an die
baden württembergische politik waren
wird cannabis endlich legalisiert
die geige sich weiterhin thomas
waldvogel er ist politologe und hat die
wahlprogramme der parteien
durchgearbeitet
thomas wie sieht's aus wann wird
cannabis legalisiert und
entkriminalisiert ja das sind zwei
fragen die frage der legalisierung wird
bundespolitisch diskutiert und
entschieden derzeit sind aber die
mehrheitsverhältnisse so dass sich eine
legalisierung von cannabis auf
bundespolitischer ebene nicht
durchsetzen dass die entkriminalisierung
da geht's aber auf landesebene
wie sieht es da bei den einzelnen
parteien aus wie stehen sie zu dem thema
wenn es jetzt um die frage konkret um
die entkriminalisierung gilt in baden
württemberg ist es so dass sich hier
nicht nur linke spd und grüne für eine
entkriminalisierung aussprechen sondern
auch die fdp selbst die cdu hat die
traditionellen vorbehalte in großen
teilen abgelegt und einzig die afg hat
eine ablehnende stark ablehnende
position gegenüber der
entkriminalisierung
also fazit die entkriminalisierung die
kann auf landesebene geklärt werden und
da muss man jetzt sehen nach der
landtagswahl zu welcher mehrheitsbildung
es kommen wird ob cannabis in baden
württemberg entkriminalisiert wird oder
nicht
[Musik]
ein anderes thema das echt viele
menschen interessiert sind die hohen
mieten den baden württemberg auch hier
in stuttgart und hier treffe ich gleich
einen jungen mann der seit langer langer
zeit eine wohnung macht
[Musik]
ich bin anderes grund warum ich bin 23
jahre alt im moment in der ausbildung
und suche nach einer wohnung sucht jetzt
seit ungefähr ein bisschen länger als
ein halbes jahr würde ich sagen und die
probleme sind dann schon auch ja oftmals
die wohnung zu finden in der richtigen
preisklasse weil als auszubildender kann
ich mir halt nicht alles leisten und das
ist dann schon so ein bisschen
frustrationen wenn man dann halt eben
zehn wohnungen anschreibt und davon nur
zwei zurück schreiben und die dann auch
absagen sind im moment wohl ich noch bei
meinen eltern oder wieder bei meinen
eltern
ich kann die ganze wohnung nutzen aber
es ist trotzdem manchmal fühlt sich ein
bisschen an als ob ich einfach nur in
einem kleinen zimmer bin und nicht viel
machen kann
ja ich fühle mich ein bisschen ein
geschenk meiner freiheiten und das ist
nicht unbedingt die schuld von meinen
eltern oder so aber es ist einfach
dieses zuhause wohnen in dem alter ist
noch ein bisschen ja ich hätte gerne wie
gesagt meine eigene wohnung
[Musik]
ich bin im moment in der
erzieherausbildung im ersten
ausbildungsjahr verdient einfach nicht
so viel geld und dann kann ich mir keine
wohnung leisten die eben sehr teuer ist
und selbst wgs zehn quadratmeter zimmer
kosten zum teil so viel das ist mir
einfach nicht leisten kann
ich bin hier in stuttgart groß geworden
und das ist mir ich weiß nicht mehr
gefällt stuttgart sehr gut ist schon
eine frage die ich mir gestellt habe so
wo geht es hin wenn junge menschen
keinen platz mehr finden in der stadt
jetzt steht die landtagswahl in baden
württemberg an
was ist denn deine frage an die politik
meine frage an die politik ist wann gibt
es endlich genügend wohnungen die
bezahlbar sind für junge auszubildende
und studenten die mit ja wann auch die
frage wollen wir weitergeben
thomas was haben die parteien im angebot
wenn es um bezahlbares wohnen für junge
menschen geht für spd und linke
beispielsweise sind dort die schlagworte
wie mieten deckel mietpreis bremse oder
auch eine sozialquote im wohnungsbau
wichtig die grünen ergänzen das ganze
noch mit so einer nachhaltigen nase also
das thema flächenverbrauch spielt dann
noch eine höhere rolle wie sieht es bei
cdu fdp und afd aus hier sind ihr
marktliberale position zu finden also
zum einen geht es darum dass die
menschen ermöglicht wird wohneigentum zu
bilden und das zweite ist die kosten zu
senken
für den erwerb beispielsweise von
baugrundstücken oder auch von immobilien
so gut zum beispiel dass die
grunderwerbsteuer gesenkt werden soll
aber es geht auch darum dass
baugenehmigung schneller vergeben werden
oder das baurecht vereinfacht wird
thomas weshalb jemand der aktuellen
ausbildung ist oder studiert von der
nächsten regierung zu erwarten
ja das hängt entscheidend davon ab wie
sich diese regierung zusammensetzen wird
in jedem fall ob regulierende maßnahmen
oder ihre marktliberale maßnahmen sind
alle maßnahmen die im bereich wohnbau
politik getroffen werden eher
langfristige maßnahmen und werden und
keine kurzfristigen effekte haben
fazit es gibt also unterschiedliche
positionen wie man zu mehr bezahlbaren
wohnungen kommt aber das problem ist
natürlich es wird lange dauern bis diese
wohnung gebaut sind das heißt wer jetzt
studiert oder jetzt in ausbildung ist
wird doch das kann nicht digitalisierung
an schulen beziehungsweise nicht
vorhandene digitalisierung an schulen
ein anderes thema das viele von euch
aufregt deswegen treffen hier in
stuttgart eine junge lehrerin
mein name ist anna-lena lutz ich bin
grundschullehrerin und konrektorin von
der lerchen rheinschule in stuttgart und
ich bin 29 jahre alt das karo naja war
ein ganz besonderes wir haben es letztes
jahr 'mal zum schuljahresende als ein
merkwürdiges jahr zusammengefasst
gerade in diesen ersten wochen keiner
hat damals einsehen können wie lange wir
dann tatsächlich von zu hause lernen und
es war sicherlich ein seltsames gefühl
die kinder von einem tag auf den anderen
nicht mehr zu sehen
eine lehrer dann ohne kinder das macht
irgendwie heim großen sinn und mir hat
richtig was gefehlt natürlich auch
irgendwo die sorge nicht zu wissen wie
der alltag von den kindern ist
wir waren bei der einrichtung und bei
der suche von einem
kommunikationsplattform sicherlich auf
uns gestellt haben da viele eigene
arbeitsstunden reingesteckt aber das
ganze einfach aus der motivation heraus
dass wir unsere kinder erreichen wollen
und es hat sich definitiv gelohnt
es war bestimmt nicht immer einfach ich
bin grundschullehrerin und kein experte
aber ich muss sagen habe ich auch ein
bisschen stolz auf uns
aber wir machen doch jetzt deutschen ein
kriegskind mein motto ist immer so ein
bisschen dass man kinder nicht
unterschätzen darf und dass man nicht
unterschätzen darf was die schon alles
können auch digital
wir müssen jetzt das was wir gelernt
haben mit in die zukunft nehmen ist
nicht wieder weglegen nicht ipad zur
seite tun und sagen ich habe nur noch
mal eine grüne tafel sondern
herausfinden wie wir beides einsetzen
können es ist ganz bei sich im laden
ich glaube den schulen zur seite zu
stellen wer wahnsinnig wichtig also hier
jemanden zu haben der vielleicht auch
mehrere schulen betreut
das wäre sicherlich etwas das uns auf
dem weg der digitalisierung helfen
könnte
welche frage hast du jetzt an die
politik wie wird digitalisierung und all
das was wir jetzt wären krone gelernt
haben nachhaltig an allen schulen
verankert was sagen die parteiprogramme
dazu thomas waldvogel da sind die
parteiprogramme noch so zumindest meine
erkenntnis in der lektüre noch relativ
diffus und in einem entstehungsprozess
wo viele impulse aus der pandemie zeit
auch einfließen die kontroversen sind
natürlich auch erkennbar die frage nach
datenschutz spielt eine rolle gegenüber
schnellen technischen und vielleicht
auch effizienten lösungen und was steht
da jetzt ganz konkret in denen in den
parteiprogrammen wie unterschiedlich
sind die parteien zum beispiel in puncto
digitale endgeräte
da sehen wir dass es parteien gibt die
der kostenfreien ausstattung von
schülerinnen schüler mit digitalen
endgeräten zu stimmen beispielsweise die
spd aber auch die linke aber auch cdu
und fdp und grüne und fdp die grünen
haben eine mittelposition die
sympathischen neutral zu dieser
forderungen und die fdp will das schul
taschenrechner modell das heißt dass die
schülerin beziehungsweise die eltern die
geräte erwerben und dann einen zuschuss
erhalten
die lehrerin hat im gespräch mit uns
auch gesagt super wer ein it für jede
schule steht dazu was in den
drei programmen das werden viele
befürworten
das ist aber die frage der finanzierung
aber mir ist nicht bekannt dass dort
schon konkrete konzepte vorliegen also
fazit der wille ist da die konzepte der
parteien sind immer noch relativ
schwammig ein weiteres thema das ihr uns
genannt hat war das thema klimaschutz
und umwelt politik
ich bin jetzt in heidelberg treffen
gleich you run von den centers for
future ich bin ihrer landschaft 30 jahre
alt lebe in mannheim und arbeitet in
heidelberg und engagiere mich hier für
den klimaschutz und wünsche mir ein
engagiertes vorgehen gegen den
klimawandel
klimawandel ist mir glaube ich erst mal
in der fünften klasse begegnet und
damals dachte ich überweise noch dass
das eigentlich ja alles klar ist und
bestimmt bald erledigt ist und seitdem
verfolgt mich das auch mit dem alter wo
dann klar wie wichtig das eigentlich
wirklich ist und wie wenig das
tatsächlich passiert sind jetzt auch
sowas 3019 bei den cites for future
tatsächlich durch die damaligen klima
streiks der freiheit ist future man sich
mehr wirklich gesagt habe ich kann jetzt
nicht immer nur mich aufregend darüber
wie alles läuft ich muss irgendwas tun
und mein politisches engagement zeigen
ein doktorand der linguistik und da ich
mich als wissenschaftler verstehe habe
ich dann gesagt ich nehme mal das
selbstvertrauen mit und geht da rein und
versuche da meine fähigkeiten mit
einzubringen
wir möchten natürlich erreichen dass die
klimaerwärmung aufgehalten wird dass das
1,5 grad ziel erreicht wird am besten
natürlich noch mehr das wäre schön
natürlich geht schon alles sehr langsam
voran in der welt und natürlich ist das
auch wahnsinnig frustrierend gerade wenn
man in so einer wissenschafts community
ist und da die fakten alles auf den
tisch hat und weiß genau was man
erreichen müsste und welche dinge
geändert werden müssten
aber das müssen wir eben der
gesellschaft zusammen klärten und da
muss man wahnsinnig viel arbeit leisten
um das zu kommunizieren und gemeinsam
anzupacken
wir brauchen in diesem land diverse
dinge wir brauchen eine eine bau wende
wenn wir sind anders häuser bauen wir
müssen eine mobilitäts werde hinkriegen
die den namen verdient hat wir müssen
wegkommen möglichst vom
verbrennungsmotor vom auto überhaupt
eigentlich wir müssen die landwirtschaft
anders gestalten
das kann man ewig fortführen diese liste
was wäre dann deine frage an die
parteien im land eine ganz konkrete
frage wer wie die sehr klimarelevanten
themen der gebäude und der mobilität in
den nächsten jahren so angegangen werden
können das nicht wieder die
benachteiligten am ende auf den kosten
sitzen bleiben wie zb die liter bringt
wieder thomas waldvogel dazu
politikwissenschaftler zunächst
vielleicht das thema wohnen und
wohnungen und klimaschutz wie sieht es
da aus was sagen die parteien dazu da
gibt es sehr viele unterschiedliche
maßnahmen zum beispiel die
verpflichtende installation von
fotovoltaikanlagen auf neubauten und da
sehen wir dass die spd und linke den
durchaus zustimmen die grünen das sogar
noch weiterführen wollten auf
bestandsgebäude gleichzeitig aber auch
ablehnungen sehen beispielsweise cdu und
fdp die die installation von
photovoltaikanlagen als kostentreiber
und bauherr vor allem auch
identifizieren oder aber dann auch mit
einer ganz starken gegenmeinung die afg
so eine photovoltaik anlage kostet eine
ganze menge geld wird es dann alles auf
die mieter geht also da gibt es auch
viele förderprogramme um das von den
kosten her gering zu halten aber in der
tat kann es natürlich schon sein dass
das durchschlägt zum thema klimaschutz
und mobilität was sagen die parteien da
ja klimaschutz mobilität natürlich eine
mega thema also auch öffentlicher
nahverkehr und die kostenfreie nutzung
dessen gesehen wird dass hier einzig die
linke einer solchen kostenfreien nutzung
zustimmen würde
die grünen hingegen eine neutrale
position einnehmen einfach deshalb weil
die zuständigkeit bei den stadt und
landkreisen originär liegen würde eine
ablehnende position der fdp
cdu fdp und spd ein aber aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen die spd
beispielsweise weil sie einen 365 euro
jahresticket favorisiert
die anderen parteien eher weil sie das
als realitätsfremd halten dankeschön
thomas und mein fazit außer der afg
bekennen sich alle großen parteien zum
klimaschutz
doch wer dafür letztendlich wie viel
bezahlt ist oft nicht zu erkennen
falls euch das ist alles ein bisschen zu
schnell ging unten sind alle
parteiprogramme der parteien in baden
württemberg noch mal verlinkt und auch
ein weg zum automaten war eingepackt da
könnt ihr unterschiedliche thesen zu
unterschiedlichen themen einfach nochmal
durchklicken